the Merc with a mouth may be in for a
marvel sized reality check if or more
realistically when he joins the MCU
after enjoying two refreshingly batty
films from Deadpool 1 & 2 audiences
worldwide have been wondering what's
coming next
fans of the no-holds-barred superhero
franchise were initially over the moon
when star Ryan Reynolds recently
announced that the potty-mouth hero
would soon be making his MCU debut with
the tentatively titled Deadpool 3 now
officially in production under the
Marvel Studios shingle by way of its
parent company Disney it seems MCU
mastermind Kevin Feige could be eyeing
major changes for the Deadpool franchise
the latest little nugget of MCU rumor
madness comes via the not super reliable
rumour mongers over it we got this
covered who are reporting an alleged
emphasis on alleged Marvel insiders
claim that Feige is looking to replace
some key creatives behind the Deadpool
franchise don't worry he's apparently
not looking to push Ryan Reynolds out of
the picture and recast the role of wait
Wilson
but according to W GTC Feige is looking
to take some creative control out of
Reynolds hands as a reminder Reynolds
has served as producer and a key
creative force behind both Deadpool and
Deadpool to handpicking director david
leitch for the sequel and even earning a
writing credit for his work on that film
it's been speculated that Reynolds was
pushing to bring the creative team
behind Deadpool to back for the upcoming
sequel including his co-writers Rhett
Reese and Paul Wernick Feige according
to the rumor isn't sold on bringing
leech back to helm Deadpool 3 and is
reportedly keen on bringing ant-man and
la subscribes Chris McKenna and Eric
Sommers onboard to fully marbleize the
sequel way to pull the rug out from
under these folks Marvel fake laugh
hiding real pain as for what those
supposed changes could mean for Deadpool
3 it's possible that the Merc we've come
to know and love over the course of the
first two deliriously crass Deadpool
movies may be toned way way down of
course that may not be entirely a bad
thing while the first two Deadpool
movies have served as a welcome
departure from the increasingly
homogenized realm of superhero cinema
even the characters most ardent fans
would likely admit the winking meta
stick was wearing a little thin by the
end of Deadpool 2 still that wickedly
self-aware approach has spawned a hyper
specific style in the movies and it sort
of implies
able to imagine what Deadpool 3 might
look like without it you might want to
look away for this this little piggy
went ooh Deadpool remains a singular
voice in the Marvel canon so much so
that a stark change in tone might leave
his new flick all but unrecognizable
from its cinematic brethren not to
mention the comics today the decision by
Reynolds and the Deadpool creatives to
lean headlong into the comics special
brand of wacky is a big part of what is
set the franchise apart from every other
superhero story out there if team Marvel
is indeed looking to shake things up the
changes might be to the detriment of
Deadpool 3 however as we previously
mentioned WGT sees reports is in no way
confirmed then it may in fact all be a
bunch of hot air let's face it
WG TC isn't exactly known for their
pinpoint accuracy plus Phi G is a pretty
smart guy and changing or eliminating
everything that makes the Deadpool
franchise unique doesn't exactly sound
like his style regardless of whether a
change in direction is in the cards it
does appear that a good deal of the
previous flicks cast may be back for
Deadpool 3 though some fan faves may not
be TJ Miller who appeared as Wilson's
buddy weasel in the first two films and
brianna hildebrand who portrayed the
wonderfully surly negasonic teenage
warhead are both still on the fence WG
TC has reported that Hildebrand may not
return but again their reports should be
taken with a grain of salt and according
to CB R Miller is iffy on the prospect
of reprise in his role though he is
under contract just once I'm going to
find a planet of people that are worse
than me at everything whole budget
functional idiots I'm gonna go there I'm
gonna be their Superman isn't a
candidate Marvel is apparently eager to
bring two of Deadpool two standouts back
for the new film however Screen Rant
reports ed says he beets has a
three-picture deal and is set to return
his Domino and Josh Brolin has a similar
deal that should ensure that he'll
reprise the role of cable at least
another time or two according to slash
film with those heavy hitters seemingly
on board for Deadpool 3 it seems even
more likely Kevin Feige and Marvel will
stay the course weaving the r-rated
jaw-droppingly vulgar wave Wilson we all
know and love into the MCU fabric this
is our sincere hope because without his
potty mouth is Deadpool even Deadpool at
all we think not will be filling you in
on all the Deadpool 3 news that's fit to
report as soon as it becomes available
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]